حتى يتسنى للمبنى الصمود في وجه القوه
الهائله الناجمه عن الزلازل يتعين عليهم
امتصاصه اكبر قدر ممكن من الطاقه التي
تولدها الهزه اليابان ودول مثل تشيلي
والصين وايطاليا والمكسيك وبيرو وتركيا
معرضه للزلازل فتبنى التقنيات بدرجات
متفاوته ومنها تقنيه الاساسات المعزوله
ومن المباني الشهيره التي تستخدمها مبنى
الكابيتول في ولايه يوتا حيث صمم لتحمل ما
يصل الى زلزال بقوه 7.3 درجه على مقياس
ريختر ايضا تقنيه المثبط الكتلي تعتمد على
كتله ثقيله متارجحه تعمل كبندول مركزي
مصمم للتارجح عكس الانحناءات مثل مبنى
تايبيه 101 في تايوان بالاضافه الى مبنى
برج خليفه في الامارات كذلك تقنيه الجسر
المركزي لامتصاص الصدمات بين مبنيين عاليي
الطول عاده مثل برج بتروناس التوام في
ماليزيا في الولايات المتحده تم تصميمه
معظم المباني لتنهار بشكل محسوب والهدف هو
الحفاظ على الارواح هناك البيوت بالخيزران
او البامبو في اندونيسيا وامريكا الجنوبيه
لما يتمتع به من قوه شد يتم تدعيمه
بالاسمنت بعد ذلك او الطين
[موسيقى]